this video on cubes is very similar to
the one on squares if you've understood
the concept of squares the concept of
cubes will be stress-free let us get to
the basics first look at this number on
the board is read as 7 raised to 3 and
raised to 3 is called cubed so the
number can be called 7 cubed why do we
have a distinct name 4 raised to 3 well
it's the same reason as to why we have a
distinct name 4 raised to 2 it's because
raised to 3 has many applications here
is one of the practical examples assume
they have a box in the shape of a cube
assume the length of all its edges equal
3 centimeters if we remember correctly
the volume of a cube is given by side x
side x side so that will equal 3 x 3 x 3
so this is actually 3 cubed that will
give us 27 so that's one of the
practical applications of cubed or
raised to 3 but wait are we forgetting
something yes it's the units of the
answer so the units of each side are
also multiplied to get centimeters cubed
that's the precise answer the volume of
the cube is 27 centimeters cubed the
answer can also be written as 27 cubic
centimeters so we can see that when
three lengths are multiplied we utilize
the concept of cubes let's understand
another straightforward example solve 10
centimeters x 9 centimeters x 6
centimeters multiplying the lengths
gives us 540 we did not use the concept
of cubes here as we have three different
numbers but multiplying the units gives
us centimeters cubed so the answer can
also be written as 540 cubic centimeters
so whether it's squared
or cubed the units also differ
accordingly
now there is a vital property we need to
understand to understand the property
here are a few examples how do we find
the value of seven cubed it is 7 x 7 x 7
and that equals 343
-14 the whole cubed equals -14 x - 14 x
- 14
that equals - 2744 and similarly 18
cubed equals 18 x 18 x 18 which equals
5832
observe the sign of the number and the
sign of the answer if negative then
negative if positive then positive so we
can say that four cubes of numbers the
sign of the answer is same as the sign
of the number that is cube of a negative
number will result in a negative number
and the cube of a positive number will
result in a positive number